the night is short walk on girl is
directed by masaaki yuasa the man behind
mind game and if you've seen mine game
then you have an idea of what to expect
from his films the man is not a fan of
anything conventional his films and TV
series don't look like any other anime
he has a very unique style in the way he
presents his animation and his stories
are almost all very absurd strange and
dreamlike and this film is all of those
things here we follow a tome a a girl
who's extremely good at holding her
liquor
she will drink Marian from Raiders of
the Lost Ark under the table and she
embarks on a series of strange
encounters over the course of one night
and a man named senpai is lusting after
her but is too ashamed to admit it so he
decides to create a series of
coincidences so that they run into each
other by chance at least it looks like
chance even though he's planning the
whole thing this film I thought was
remarkable for a lot of different
reasons
I saw it tonight in a fairly packed
theatre actually because fathom events
is doing a special two-night release of
it so I got to see it with a crowd and
I've been thinking a lot about how to
describe the experience of watching this
film and have it be something that you
can relate to or understand because it
is so trance-like and so almost
hallucinatory that it feels like a dream
it feels like I wasn't actually watching
it and that experience I had was so
otherworldly that it's almost
transported me to a different type of
film experience and it sounds so
pretentious when I say that but it's
true I mean that's really how I felt it
reminded me of the first couple hours of
your day you know how when you wake up
you might get a shower you might eat
something
maybe you check your emails and then
later in the day you think about that
first hour that you were awake and you
were sort of adjusting to being awake
and it's almost like it didn't happen
that's like watching this film it's so
weird and so unique and I really loved
it
and it's the type of movie that upon
reflection it gets better and better
because you think about the things that
are presented for one thing at omae's
watch moves very slow whereas almost
everyone else's watch especially the
older characters is moving very fast and
a lot of these characters they feel very
depressed and they look at life in a
very cynical way whereas a Tomei looks
at life very optimistic Herr Knight
seems to be going a lot smoother than
everyone else's and it's sort of like
she's just having fun and enjoying life
and to her she has all the time in the
world but the older people surrounding
her are those with a more cynical view
of life time is very short and it's
fleeting and she takes that bouncy happy
optimism and infects the people around
her with it and in turn makes them see
life the way she sees life this film has
a lot of humor typical with a masaaki
yuasa film that's very absurd and quite
insane it's nowhere near on the level of
mind game in regards to surrealistic
imagery but I don't think it's
attempting to be that type of film
either I mean we have dance sequences we
have musical sequences songs that go on
for quite some time that I thought was
just drop-dead hilarious there's a long
drawn-out sequence entirely in someone's
subconscious and yet somehow the film
continues to be incredibly investing
because it's just so arresting like it's
it's so different and so endlessly
unique that you can't really stop
looking at it which is why it's a little
disappointing that sometimes the humor
falls back on some anime tropes and
cliches but gratefully it's it's really
just one in particular that
unfortunately is one of the most common
cliches i've ever seen in comedy anime
and it's a man groping a woman and then
getting punched in the face repeatedly I
talked about this just a few months ago
in my review for the film fireworks it's
old we've we've been there we've done
that it's not really funny anymore it's
just it's old and this film has that a
few times too but what I also loved
about it is that you can interpret it in
so many different ways there is really
no concrete interpreter
that I think I will ever latch on to you
could look at it through the lens of the
pain and the confusion of adolescents
like this whole night is just these
characters blooming and blossoming into
the adults they're going to be one day I
mean you can see all of this in the
narrative and in some of the visuals and
it helps to have a knowledge of the
culture that's on display as well and
some of the significance of the things
that are in the background of the shots
and there's just so much to glean and I
can't wait to see it again to be honest
I'm gonna give the night a short walk on
girl and a - this film will probably
leave some people scratching their heads
understandably especially if you've
never seen a masaaki yuasa film his
films are very different but this is the
type of just pure inventiveness and
creativity that I yearn to see in a
movie especially in animation form so
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
you